how would you describe what we're gonna
see in the new season well I mean it's
always the twists and turns it's very
tumultuous we know that no one can
replace James Kennedy baby situations
the season as anyway so we're in for a
season of surprises it sounds like yes
serum like let's do this December 3rd
I'm excited
Vanderpump rules is back and from what
the cast tells et it's gonna be the
shows a best season yet our viewers
gonna be surprised what goes down this
season they're always surprised I'm
surprised if I'm surprised they're going
to be risky why do you always find
yourself in the heart of the drama it's
hard for him to like contain what he
really feels like it's a little bit of
trouble but you get in trouble too you
get a one of the craziest insults I've
ever heard I love that insult like if
that's an insult I'll take it you know
it's cute do you think I'm stupid
these guys they're so entwined but
that's what makes the show magic you
know because it's the authentic
relationships that you know so yeah it's
a lot of fun you'll see friendships of
mine like drastically change and I think
that'll be interesting you call nobody
your co-workers and
and then you get to know them through
the process of falling in love with them
and some people you don't love anymore
that was a little bit of sadness and
some of the dynamics in relationships
change as they struggle to grow up
struggle yeah it's kind of good to see
everybody involved you know I mean we've
been these Hollywood kids for so long
you know it's nice to see everybody
growing up and you know get married they
talk about kids moving into a home Jax
Jax is 39 and we are Pun we growing up
but I do agree I think our problems are
adult problems so now there are real
adult problems it's not cheating
there are some cheating scandals
for the most of you know the most of us
there's still like Jax like after girl
in Vegas or Kristen did this bad thing
like she did when she was 24 years old
it's more I think things are very
deep-rooted and that actually tends to
make them blow up a little bit more
because it's like you hurt me you didn't
piss me off so I feel like they'll be a
lot of Tears but I think a lot more
laughter to ask you about Kristin's fall
in a trailer oh my god
me and Brittney miss it it's like the
most infamous fall and I cannot wait to
actually find people watch it that's
called I was drunk I am like a baby
giraffe on Ice King John for summer but
I was definitely intoxicated here's my
legacy it is a moment to behold yeah
that was so trashy all off the price we
that season yeah they're bad I think
maybe that yeah Derby I definitely was
disappointed a lot of this season in
people and the way they acted
we've become so solid we're like we've
chosen each other's family but we are so
also brighter die with each other that
we've gone through so much that it's
like we're stuck with each other and I
think that when anything goes wrong or
there's a fight or you know an
altercation it's that so much more
intense and sad so I feel like heartfelt
is the best way to describe us it was a
good summer so I'm hoping it's that
translates into a good season I don't
think it can get worse than last year so
fill me up from here have you had to
boil it down to one word and it can be
drama or dramatic how did you describe
emotional how about gripping it's
gripping okay I'm gonna say was the best
and worst year in my life
all tied up in one wonderful
I'll take a wonderful this a lot of
carts but mostly wonderful that sounds
like Dana couples to me ashamed of you
we should be ashamed of yourself it
could be the best season ever
[Music]